but it's still crazy to see all the
polls were wrong off by like
seven percent four to seven well no no i
i want to stop you there because i think
we keep saying the polls were wrong
the solstice lies some polls were wrong
some polls were propaganda
right okay we have to keep in mind like
media polls are frequently
they are propaganda or they are intended
to be the basis for a story a narrative
and and you can't think about them the
same the reason that the
actual like pole people are are are
upset or that are are concerned about
the future of their industry
is that the the behind the scenes polls
were also wrong
right like the the ones that are given
to corporate and lobbying clients etc
about
i mean i had all of these people coming
to me saying there is no chance susan
collins is going to win
you got to stop saying that you know
like like i just kept saying you know
what i just i think she knows how to win
maine
and then and they're saying you know
look we have we got our internals
you know she's not going to be on this
committee anymore we're talking to the
you know to the other side that kind of
thing
and then of course she wins easily so it
is it is a fact that pulls our
propaganda
and i know immediately there's going to
be mainstream journalists there's going
to be leftists being like ah conspiracy
theories no no hold on there there are
many polls that are legit there are many
polls that are overt propaganda and they
function as such
ian let me ask you a question okay would
you be in favor
of taking some tax money and invest and
using that to invest in new technologies
that could improve
american energy independence wow that's
a vague question tim
would i thought that was very specific
would you be in favor of allocating some
of the us how much is some
first off it's just your opinion some it
could be anything i'm just asking if
you think i'm not gonna drag you here
yeah i would it sounds great doesn't it
sounds awesome okay let me mark you down
for favor's green new deal okay
now let me ask you a question would you
be in favor of a policy that
dramatically overhauls the entire
medical industry
and bans private insurance
uh no oh opposes green new deal you see
you can ask questions and what they'll
do then is let's say they'll they'll
show a thing saying support it'll say
green new deal support oppose
and they won't tell you what they're
asking those are the propaganda polls
there are polls that will show you the
methodology they'll show the questions
they ask and that's what you have to do
when you go and try and figure out what
they're really talking about well the
biggest thing that has been plaguing the
polling industry and i don't want to get
so off tangent on bar but um
so someone who you should actually have
on the program emily eakins who's the
head of
polling at the cato institute
and previously at the reason foundation
has done phenomenal research over the
past several years about the difficulty
she was the one who was the source of
that pull that so many people cite
about the unwillingness of people to
share their true views
right um and kind of seeking out the shy
trump voter or the shy
conservative voter in lots of different
respects and it's
very difficult to do it you almost have
to one of the polls not
from something she commissioned but one
that i saw from this cycle
uh behind the scenes had this hilarious
question in it i think i can share it
now that uh
you know it's well in the past but it
was uh do you know someone
who you believe supports president trump
but would be unwilling
to say that publicly for fear of the
reaction
okay and so they have this percentage
that's like this is how many it's a huge
number you know say
and then the follow-up question to those
who said yes is does that previous
question describe you
and a lot of them say yes like it's a
huge portion of themselves
it's because they've been prepped for it
right otherwise it's like some strange
person calls me and they ask me whether
i support this guy everybody says it's
racist i'm not gonna say yes but but
also because the way the question is
framed
it could have repercussions on them yes
so it's basically it sounds like they're
coming at you as someone who's
sympathetic
to that you know having an impact on you
but yeah you know
what i was saying i i i love it they
they
they put out this clip of me saying 49
state landslide over and over
again because i was for one saying
here's the hypotheticals
like for instance there's a lot of
videos where i'd say something like look
if trump pardoned
all non-violent drug offenders and and
issued an executive order legalizing pot
the federal level
49 state landslide and so i'm not
literally predicting this i'm saying
if trump does something crazy this is
what happened which is the one state he
would lose in that scenario
what's the one state yeah he would lose
in that scenario i don't know 49
oregon yeah
you know the point to it was basically
there's hypotheticals i kind of lost my
train of thought on
why i was busy why i was bringing that
up but you know back to
polls i guess was the general the i
don't want to
you know stay too long on polls but
because i know you there's so many other
news things to talk about but the one
thing that i do want people to keep in
mind is
they were broken last time around oh
they said
the vast majority did not fix it and the
and the handful of places that got it
right last time around
and worked to fix it okay including
trafalgar and other places like that
just got
bashed over and over by both pollsters
and like the pole bros
the people who just analyzed polls for a
living who write for a lot of these
media sites and at the end of the day
they ended up being a ton more accurate
even as they were being criticized over
and over again um and
one of the big aspects of this that i
think kept getting cited by these pole
bros was
well you're not looking at the granular
you know precinct level data the way
that we are like we have
we have the true cross you know here you
know and you don't really know what it's
what is in it and that was where they
had some of the biggest misses
it's why they got so many of these house
races wrong the the cook report
for instance uh not to single them out
because so many people were wrong but
dave wasserman
there literally had a tweet up where he
said i wish that i could erase
everything that i've written
in 2020 about the outcome in the house
and revert to what i said
in december 2019 or whatever when i said
republicans would pick up five so i i i
remember my train of thought it was that
the one thing i predicted pretty much
spot on his money did was the polls
would be wrong
and one of the reasons i gave is you
have all these people who lie about you
all the time
they accuse you of being a bigot and a
racist and all these things
the media is constantly full of
falsehoods and then when you get a phone
call
you know hi i'm with you know abc
washington post poll
do you support donald trump no uh no not
me
by nothing i never let any of them over
for thanksgiving
i mean okay i guess i can't any of them
though for anyway
you you see how the media treated that
guy you know i remember that guy who
posted the the video of nancy pelosi
slowed down and they were like they
chose pic his picture his name where he
works
you had the the guy who made the meme of
trump body slamming the cnn guy
and they're like we will publish his
name if he ever does this again
so when the media calls you and says hi
friend
do you support donald trump we're the
media you can trust us
and and keep in mind did you see the any
of the
uh most recent tech hearing the holly uh
little bit it's just it's just circled
so yeah so the most interesting
there were two interesting things from
that interaction one was zuckerberg
saying that he didn't know whether they
tracked every time an employee had
looked at
uh someone's facebook messages secretly
he said that and secondly secondly the
admission that
um they actually have a program
that zuckerberg sort of initially said
he didn't recognize the name but then it
became clear that he kind of knew what
holly was talking about
that they haven't owned their own
internal program that is designed to
share
information across big tech about the
activities of people on other platforms
in order to inform their way that
facebook treats them
in other words that like tracking
someone's youtube comments right and
then using them in other words you think
you think you're working separately and
that you're communicating separately
but if everything is just going into a
dump of
this person needs to be downgraded
silence
that i mean that's wow and on
that reminds me of what happened to
sargon where he said some naughty word
on yeah yeah
you're familiar with sargon i'm familiar
with this but yes what what was uh
remind me he didn't yeah from patreon
yes so for those on a familiar patreon
is like a you know
people can sign up to give you a certain
amount of money and then you release
content over a certain period of time
sargon aka carl benjamin he's a youtuber
he's a podcast uh new one called the
lotus eaters shout out
shouted him out before um he did a live
stream
with a very very tiny live stream only a
few thousand people
and he called them white i think he
called them like uh
something like white n-word or whatever
and he was making a point that
the things you do to describe other
people is how you actually are so you're
describing yourself
it was an obscure two-hour stream
right in the middle where he said this
and patreon found it
apparently someone submitted it to
patreon and said look at this and they
went okay
nuked nuked his account all of his
income well not always but his income
from patreon just gone
so they said yes we take off you know
offline behavior into account how you
act on other platforms
which was really i think people don't
understand that that's where we're
headed
like that is absolutely where we are
headed and it's not going to be people
always try to scare you about some
situation where government does these
things
it's not that it's not going to be that
it's it's corporate america it's the
people who sound like a liberal
well it seems how they used to sound
well how they used to sound exactly look
this is this is a very real thing that
is a transition that is happening and
that
the i would say more the kamala harris
wing of the democratic party once
which is to say we are going to use
corporate america to weaponize or to
uh administrate our woke program even as
we
you know we put it out through taxpayer
funds in in the public schools etc
but corporate america doesn't want to
fight this stuff they're happy as long
as they make money right right and so
they're happy with
you know an america last foreign policy
where where china
is just this wonderful trading partner
and taking away all of these american
jobs and making all sorts of
cheap crap that we can sell to people um
here in america and
uh and you know everybody should be
happy all the big tech companies they've
been profiting so much from this past
year
they're only going to continue and
meanwhile small business america gets
absolutely crushed cnbc reporting
this week that their uh that their
optimism has only gone down
since biden was uh was elected and that
i think is going to continue to be the
dynamic here and you have these major
corporations that are come
that are going to come and effectively
crush you through
a thousand sort of little things that
you can't use anymore
you can't be on this platform you can't
do and then and then it becomes
you can't be a part of our you know
hotel rewards program
you know you can't fly on our airline oh
yeah some people i mean you look you
look at
city no you're looking at uh enrique
tario they have so much power to cut you
off
yeah completely your water is cut off i
mean they can do garcetti
yeah garcetti and allie said he was
gonna cut your water off if you had
people over
somehow they didn't do that when hunter
biden went to that house and partied
with
we have a first amendment right to
peaceably assemble the constitution
doesn't say for what if i want to
peaceably assemble to discuss episodes
of spongebob squarepants so be it
so if i have a party and i'm in la the
constitution guarantees me that right he
says i'm going to shut your water off
that is a human rights violation and it
literally is
i mean i can't even imagine what that
would do to you know someone who had
health needs who
you know turning off their power and
their diabetic yeah i mean yes no more
refrigerator no more insulin
oxygen this is this is how how
absolutely insane things are getting
what people don't realize
about this kind of like dystopian
nightmare
you've got all these people that are
effectively in the matrix
going along with all of this and that's
that's
freaky so you think we're going with
social credit score totally
about your water and your electricity
joe biden
as part of his pack with bernie sanders
has a plan for a publix uh credit
scoring agency based off of your
privilege criteria something like what
does it means that if you're a straight
white male you get a negative score
now i'm not kidding you so this was
written about there's an organization
that works with um
like this i forgot what's called it's a
credit you know like
they write about their write reports on
different credit agencies and it's like
an internal
corporate thing i did a segment on this
they said we don't know how biden
would even implement this because it's a
violation of the law it's violation of
civil rights law
to create a public scoring agency that
gives you credit based on your like
you know privileged criteria or
something like that when you when you
when you see something like that
and then you look at what they tried in
california with with prop 16 repeal
it was yeah repeal prop 209 which was
their civil rights provision in the
constitution it failed
it starts in california it comes to the
rest of the country
if the critical race theorists have
their way they will absolutely
repeal the civil rights act of 19. so
they want to put like a star of david on
my chest because i'm a white guy
no no no no no no no a little piece of
flair no no give me a little
i'd like to buy a house and they're
going to say well your public credit
score is 470 because you're a straight
line we deserve most of our loans for
ethnic minorities i'm sorry you're not
welcome
look i mean ebermex candy you know the
whole passage in his book is about how
you know capitalism is racism and racism
is capitalism and those things are like
totally united together
and so to me this is a this is a
situation where
this new administration wants to buy off
the the woke progressives with
these various aspects of policy even as
they refuse to do anything that people
who actually
care about class divides in america and
about
uh the economy that's moved you know
really up into the last couple of years
in a really negative direction
in this sense not addressing any of
those things just pretending that it
doesn't exist and trying to satisfy it
with
diversity quotas and the like thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you